yeah so but while I have the chance I'd
like to thank the organizers for
organizing this nice good camp and for
giving me the opportunity to give a talk
so yesterday in the first part of this
tutorial ivana set up the basics of
Markov chains and then I talked about
one particular method for bounding the
mixing time of a markov chain coupling
and we're going to continue on that
theme today so in particular I'll talk
about a Markov chain for sampling from
colorings of a graph proper colorings
and we'll look at a coupling argument
for bounding the mixing time and once we
sorry once we have this argument in
place we'll look at it a little bit more
closely and see in what ways the
analysis can be made a little bit more
clever as well as simplified by a
technique called path coupling and then
in the end i'll talk about exact
sampling algorithms so so far what we've
seen is that coupling allows us to give
bounds on the total variation distance
so you're guaranteed to be within say
some epsilon of the stationary
distribution but can you use a Markov
chain to get exact samples so so that's
the question that okay so okay before I
before I get into all that though I
wanted to make a few remarks about what
I said yesterday so number one yesterday
we saw an order N squared upper bound on
the mixing time of shuffling by random
transpositions and I should have
mentioned that actually the mixing time
is known to be of order at most n log N
and
there's a lower bound as well and this
this can be proved using strong
stationary times which at a high level
or random times where you're guaranteed
to be at the stationary distribution so
when I talk about exact sampling if we
have time I'll say something about that
and the second thing is that I skipped
over how to construct the maximal or
optimal coupling which achieves the
total variation distance even though
that's not going to be necessary for for
anything that will do it's pretty easy
and I think it's useful to know so you
want to construct a coupling of two
distributions mu and nu which achieves
the total variation distance so you want
to get you want to define random
variables x and y so that as far as
possible they're equal so what would you
do well kind of looking at this picture
you you seem to have probability a delta
what is this gamma gamma where you can
make these to be equal so how would you
do that you could say with probability
gamma choose X to be equal to Y and
according to the distribution which is
minimum of
we love x new of X but normalized so we
normalize it bite gap okay and what do
you do with the rest of the probability
so with probability 1 minus gamma just
choose x and y independently and sort of
put them in these regions by which i
mean choose x according to u of x minus
mu of X and normalized so this and
independently for example you could
choose why according to me love x minus
so it's pretty straightforward to
construct an optical coupling okay so so
let's start with a Markov chain for
sampling colorings this is something
that it would have introduced yesterday
so we have a graph G with vertex V and
edges II and the state space of the
Markov chain is going to be Omega the
set of proper colorings orgy and we're
going to use a metropolis Markov chain
which does the following thing you
select a vertex and color pair uniformly
at random random vertex even from the
random color so for example maybe you
selected that vertex of that color and
then you check is that color something
you can update that vertex 2 by which I
mean that it does not appear in in the
neighborhood of that vertex and if
that's the case then you update it and
and you go to the next step and if it
does appear in the neighborhood then you
just stay where you are so you can check
again the detail balance conditions and
verify that the stationary distribution
of this chain would be uniform but of
course you need to
assume that it's actually a reducible
and we're going to be assuming that that
Q is bigger than Delta plus 1 so all
right so we're going to bound the mixing
time of this chain using coupling and
just to recall we had this theorem that
if I have a coupling X tyt of a Markov
chain starting at some initial states X
and Y and tau star is the first time
that they meet then the total variation
distance can be bounded by the maximum
over pairs of starting states of the
probability that x time T you have not
coupled so our aim is going to be better
to bound this probability so let me just
write that here we have it and the
theorem that will show is that if G has
maximum degree Delta and cue the number
of colors is larger than four times
Delta then the mixing time is of order n
log N and you see that there are some
constants there so here is the coupling
that we're going to use it's a very
simple coupling you generate a vertex
color pair VK uniformly at random and
you update both copies of the chain
which you know are a pair of arbitrary
colorings by attempting to update the
vertex V in both chains with the color k
and if you're able to do this then then
you go ahead and do it and if you're not
then you just stay where you are
so let's analyze the coupling and try to
see whether we can bound the probability
that the time of the you know the time
that they meet being bigger than T okay
so if I have two colorings at time T XT
and YT I'm going to define a variable dt
which is going to be the number of
vertices which have different colors in
these two colorings so I'll denote the
color at a vertex V in the coloring xt
by X T of V okay and what we're going to
do is use DT to track whether we've
coupled or not if we've coupled then dt
is 0 if we have in couples then it will
be bigger than 0 whereby we have coupled
I mean that the chains are in the same
state ok so we divide the analysis into
two things that could happen the vertex
that you pick either it could have the
same color in both the chains or it
could have a different color so first
let's look at what happens if the vertex
has a different color in in the two
Chainz an example of that and now let's
think about what would happen if you
tried to update this vertex with the
same color right that's our coupling we
pick the same color and try to update it
in both well you know you can see that
the colors here are already different so
you're not willing to increase dt by
anymore only two things could happen
either dt stays the same or decreases
and you'll see in the calculation that
it won't really matter when it stays the
same what we're interested in is
bounding the probability that it
actually decreases so in order for dt to
decrease we need to update it with the
same color and when can
so you can do that if you happen to pick
a color which doesn't occur in the
neighborhood of either of these vertices
if you haven't a pick a color like that
then you'll be able to update it in in
both of them so I've crossed out the
colors here which appear in either one
of the neighborhoods so we're left with
these two colors and you can see that if
you pick them either one of them then dt
will decrease now the probability that
you what's the probability that you pick
a pair of colors like this so you have
at most delta neighbors in the
neighborhood of B and so overall there
are two Delta colors that you don't want
to pick and so you have a choice of Q
minus 2 Delta colors so the overall
probability that DT goes down by one can
be lower bounded by the probability of
first of all choosing a vertex that has
a different color which is dt over n
times the probability of choosing one of
these good colors which is 2 minus 2
delta / q all right so with this
probability we can guarantee that dt
goes down okay so let's see what happens
in the other case when the two vertices
have the same color other vertex has the
same color in both colorings okay so in
this case you know the color is the same
in both so it can either go up or stay
the same we don't care when it stays the
same so let's just try to bound the
probability that it would go up okay so
so looking at at this particular example
why would why would it happen that DT
goes up well you could pick one of the
colors that occurs say in in the
neighborhood of this guy say this like
blue I
and then if you try to update this to
light blue you wouldn't be able to do it
here but you would be able to do it here
okay so certainly an upper bound on you
know these these bad colors is the
number of colors that appear in the
neighborhood of of the vertex so all
right so how do we bound the probability
of the dt going up in this way so we're
going to count it in a slightly funny
way so i can get the bound in the form
that i want so i say the following that
overall in in the two colorings there
are dt vertices where the color is
different right and for those dt
vertices I have you know dt times delta
vertices V that have the same color
that's an upper bound on the number of
vertices V that have the same color and
appear in the neighborhood of a vertex
with different colors okay and then I
have a choice of two colors you know for
that vertex so overall that tells me
that ZT x 2 delta / qn is a bound on the
probability of increasing and and
hopefully you can convince yourself that
that that's really all that can happen
so we put this all together and we say
you know what's the expected change in
dt in one step of this coupling so so
you see that we go down with this
probability at least so that gives me
this term and we go up with this
probability at most so that gives me
this term and putting it all together we
have dt times 1 minus Q minus 4 Delta
over N and you notice that we're we're
working under the assumption that Q is
bigger than 4 delta and so this means
that I'm getting something here which is
less than 1
that's kind of the crucial thing that in
one step of the coupling the expected dt
has decreased so how do we use this so
let us iterate this argument and if we
did that that would say that the
expected value of DT given some X naught
Y naught is bounded by the initial d
naught d 0 times this factor this
contraction factor 1 minus Q minus 4
delta / q n to the poverty and if I just
put an upper bound on d 0 of n and I get
a factor like this all right and so I'm
going to rewrite that a little bit more
conveniently as n time or bound it by n
times exponential of minus of the
quantity inside so our theorem tells us
that the total variation distance is
bounded by the probability that you
haven't coupled by time T and this is
equal to the probability that DT is
still bigger than one okay by Marcos
inequality that's bounded by the
expected value of DT and so using that
bound and asking for it to be less than
or equal to epsilon you would get that
the mixing time is bounded by by this
thing
okay so are there any questions about
that
alright so that was a nice coupling
argument and so you can ask two things
number one is that the best we can do in
terms of number of colors so we said
that if the number of colors is greater
than 4 Delta then you know we have a ban
on the mixing time can you do better
than for Delta because we know that you
know we have an irreducible chain for Q
being greater than Delta plus 1 the
second thing you can ask is can you do
better on the mixing time itself can you
do something better than order and log n
so so in fact there are arguments by
Hazen Sinclair which which show that you
would need at least n log N and roughly
the intuition is that served by a coupon
collector argument by you know by n log
n so if you go less than n log n you
haven't touched every vertex you haven't
chosen every vertex and updated its
color and so perhaps you haven't really
randomized you know every word of course
that doesn't mean that you haven't mixed
but that might be some some sort of
intuition for it ok so the thing that
I'll talk about next is an improvement
to the number of colors so this is this
theorem that was shown by jerem and
Salas and sokol which says that if q is
greater than 2 Delta then you can show
that the mixing time of the metropolis
changes of order n log N and the reason
for doing this result is that it uses
two new ingredients so the first is that
it uses sort of this idea of path
metrics on the space of your colorings
to simplify the proof and see that
you're able to to make this coupling
argument not for arbitrary states or
arbitrary pairs of colorings but
actually just four pairs of
colorings that differ at only one vertex
in their color and once once you use
this framework of the path metrics and
you know focus on coupling just these
special fares of colorings you see that
you can do something a little bit more
clever than just update the two vertices
to the same color that's going to be the
idea okay so so here's here's how you
might you know think of coming up with
this path metric idea so recall what
we've what we've done so far is said
that we have expected value of dt plus 1
and we've shown a contraction in it so
it's DT times e to the minus alpha for
some constant alpha which is bigger than
0 and that allowed us to say that the
mixing time has has this form and you
know I can I can maybe view this
intuitively in in the following way that
I had two arbitrary colorings and DT was
measuring somehow how different they
were right so it was measuring how many
vertices the colors are different at so
it's somehow measuring how different
they are and then I applied the coupling
and I got another pair of colors and I
could show that in expectation dt plus
one was smaller ok so suppose it was the
case that the fact that these two have
dt Burgess is different suppose it was
the case that that meant that you could
actually move from this coloring to this
coloring by changing the color of one
vertex at a time say you know say in in
dt steps so you can't you can't actually
do that ok always but let's say you
could so so the picture that I'm
thinking of is something like this
so I've got you know these these two
colorings and got these intermediate
colorings here okay and somehow
intuitively it should be that if these
two colors colorings differ in a large
number of verses DT is big then this
path of colorings is kind of longer okay
and then I apply the coupling and I got
some contraction and this distance is
shorter but what if I were to do the
following thing I apply the coupling to
this pair and this pair and I apply it
to this pair and this pair and so on
okay I apply a coupling I want to step
coupling to this very this pair and then
i chained together all these couplings
I'm being very big here but i chained
together all these couplings and say
well by the triangle inequality if I get
a contraction at each of these pairs
then overall I will get a contraction
it's something like that so if we could
all make that magically work somehow
then it would be enough just to bound
the expected distance in one step of the
coupling for these pairs that are close
together okay so that's that's the idea
of path coupling and here is kind of how
you can actually do it so so path
coupling was proposed by bubbly and dire
it works in the following way so so here
I've denoted these squares are supposed
to be states of the Markov chain and the
arrows denote the possible transitions
between them okay so there's some kind
of graph which is induced by the
transition matrix whose vertices are
Omega and whose edges I do not buy cake
for Colonel that's that's one graph that
we have so what we do is actually take
the states of the Markov chain and
define another
found them and the edges of this graph
are called e 0 and this the edges of
this graph they need not have anything
to do with the edges with with the
colonel all right so we we define this
graph omega e naught and we define a
length function so we assign a length XY
l of x y to each edge XY in this graph
and the only restriction on l is that it
has to be greater than or equal to 1
so you have this length function and
we're going to use it to define a path
metric on the graph so in particular a
path in this graph is just a sequence of
states like this X 0 through XR where
each each adjacent pair is an edge in
the graph the length of the path is
defined to be the sum of the lengths of
the edges and then the path metric is
just the shortest length path between
two two states all right so so you have
this path metric and this new graph and
the serum lovely entire proof is the
following so if for each edge XY in this
graph you not in this set of edges z
naught there's a coupling of the one
step distribution of the Markov chain so
you start at x and y which is which are
the endpoints of an edge in this graph
and you make the coupling and you get
out states x1 and y1 and you can show
that the expected a distance between
them in this metric row given that you
started x and y is e to the minus alpha
times the original distance row of XY
then you have a bound on the mixing time
of this form and you can compare to the
to the bottom mixing time that we had
before and you see that instead of n out
here we have log of the diameter in this
metric so the diameter is just the
maximum distance between
okay so so that's the theorem and what
this lets you do is you know just focus
on nearby states and and try to show
that there's a contraction in the
coupling there so what I'm going to talk
about is how to apply this theorem in
order to show a bound on the mixing time
in the case of colorings for the
metropolis chain when q is bigger than 2
Delta okay all right so okay so you know
we had this picture before where we
started out with two colorings and the
number of vertices that they differ at
is DT and what I'm going to try to do is
turn this into into a path metric okay
so this would be possible if I could
take this coloring and move to this
coloring through a sequence of say dt
other colorings maybe by changing one
color at a time but then the natural way
to do this is just to look at a pair of
vertices and you know if your red in one
coloring and blue in the other then
change it from red to blue but then you
might violate the proper coloring
constraint and end up with an improper
coloring right okay so so here is here
is how you can get around this so we
have our graph g as before and suppose
Omega tilde is instead of all colorings
of G so not just the proper ones but
also possibly improper ones and let me
think of what happens when I run the
same Markov chain on this extended space
Omega tilde ok so i select a vertex V
and a color k uniformly and if K is
allowed at V where now that means
that the color k doesn't appear in the
neighborhood of V then I update the
vertex to that color so here's an
example i have an improper coloring and
i happen to pick that vertex and the
colors that that are not allowed are red
and orange which which appear in its
neighborhood but if i pick anything else
i am allowed to update it so alright so
this is a Markov chain and what you can
argue is that the stationary
distribution of this Markov chain will
also be uniform on the set of all proper
colorings and you know you what ends up
happening is that if you start out with
an improper coloring when you're
updating your always updating so that
the neighbors of a vertex are now you
know properly colored with respect to it
okay so eventually you'll get rid of all
the all the improper colors and then
you'll just be walking around on proper
colorings okay so so what we're going to
do actually is use path coupling to
bound the mixing time of the Markov
chain on Omega tilde and then as we go
through the argument you should be able
to see that that you should also be able
to bound the mixing time of the Markov
chain on Omega but for now we'll just
focus on Omega tilde okay so
alright so let's set up the the path
coupling so here's what you do I'm going
to define a graph on Omega tilde and I
let X be adjacent to y if x and y differ
in the color of exactly one vertex okay
and then I let L of X Y V equal to 1
when x is adjacent to Y so now the the
path metric becomes exactly this DT when
defined on Omega tilde okay so now we
have to construct the coupling and
before we were just sort of given this
coupling where we did we pick the same
vertex in the same color and try to
update it in both but let's try to come
up with with what could be a good
coupling in this case so so when we do
the case analysis you'll see that it
might be better to do something a bit
different so now there are two two cases
that we can divide things into suppose
we start out by picking a uniformly
random vertex ok and let's say we pick
the same vertex in both chains so two
things can happen either you pick the
vertex which is where the color is
different or you pick a vertex where the
color is the same so here I've picked
the differing vertex now if we try to
understand what would happen you know if
we picked one color and try to update it
in both the chains at the same time so
so let's see what would happen well the
neighborhood of both of these vertices
is this gap is exactly the same right so
if you happen to pick a color which
already occurs in their neighborhoods
then you wouldn't be allowed to do it in
either coloring and the distance
wouldn't change on the other hand if you
picked a color that was not in the
neighborhood of the vertex V then you
would be allowed to update it in both
colorings
and you would decrease dt by one so that
seems that seems pretty good and you can
think about it and and see that you know
maybe there really isn't anything so
much better that that you could do so
the interesting thing happens in the
second case which is oh well there's
another easy case to sew so before we
get to that let's think about what would
happen if you pick the vertex which was
not a neighbor of one of the neighbors
sorry which was not one of the neighbors
of V so we talked about what happens
when you pick V then there's these
neighbors of V and then there's all the
other vertices so suppose you pick one
of those other vertices then their
colors are the same and their
neighborhoods look exactly the same so
if you update them with the same color
by picking a uniformly random color and
updating to them to the same color then
you know the distance wouldn't change at
all okay but where you could have the
distance change is in the following
situation where you pick a neighbor of V
so the neighbor itself is colored the
same thing in in both the colorings but
it sees something different so if you
think about what would happen if you
picked red here and try to update the
vertex W you would fail to do so but
here if you picked red at the same time
and try to update this we would succeed
if you didn't have read you know in the
neighborhood of W that might happen and
so you would get one extra difference at
w + DT would go up all right so so okay
that's too bad but you know presumably
it has to go up sometimes and then let's
think about what would happen if you
picked yellow so when you pick yellow
you fail in this case and you succeed
here and again you create a difference
there's two to kind of choices where you
create a difference and in all other
cases when you when you perform the
update nothing
happens to the distance the observation
is that suppose we couple in the
following way that when you pick red
here and it's not permitted to you let
us couple that with something that is
not permitted here and what is that
yellow or orange right so if you pick
orange here at the same time then that's
that's not permitted you would fail to
do it in both chains you would end up
not increasing dt ok but now you have to
make sure that you're actually doing a
coupling right you have to make sure
that this is an honest sort of step of
the chain and this is an honest step of
the tape so if you're saying when I
choose red here I choose yellow here
then you have to say when you choose
yellow here what happens here so you
know you only have this one color left
so let's let's just see what happens if
we say couple in the following way if I
choose yellow here choose red here and
if you do that well you're going to
update this with yellow and you're going
to update this with red and you'll get a
difference dt will go up right ok but
now you've gained something because
instead of having to two choices where
the the distance went up now you have
one where it goes up and one where it
just stays the same ok and that's that's
where the game comes from so this is how
we'll do person I wanted to show you
that arrow so this is how we'll define
the coupling so suppose that v is the
disagreeing vertex in the two colorings
first start by picking some random
vertex U and a color k uniformly if the
vertex you that you picked is not in the
neighborhood of V and that includes the
vertex V then just try to perform the
same update in both chains if you is in
the neighborhood of v's and do the
following thing
if the color that you picked isn't the
one that isn't one of the ones that's
different so red or yellow then you just
attempt to update you with the color k
in in both chains and the distance will
not change but if it is one of those
colors then you attempt to update you
and X with the color k but in the other
chain with with the other color so the
color which remains when you delete k
from this set okay alright so now we can
we can put all this together and and
write down what the expected change in
distance will be so we know that with
probability at least Q minus delta / q n
the distance will decrease which is
which comes from analyzing this case
because with probability 1 over N you
pick the differing vertex and then you
have Q minus Delta choices for colors
that don't appear in the neighborhood so
you get Q minus delta / q n and then if
you're in this case what happens you are
picking so the bad case when the
distance increases is when you are
picking yellow here and read here so
that's exactly one color right out of q
possible colors and this this bad sort
of scenario could happen in up to Delta
neighbors of the differing vertex so you
get a bound of Delta over qn for the
probability of DT increasing okay and so
if you put those two together you get Q
minus minus of Q minus 2 delta / q n
which will be negative when q is bigger
than to win
so you plug this into the bubbly dire
path coupling theorem we've shown that
there's a contraction and that gives you
the bound on the mixing time and
remember the diameter of Omega is so
that is bounded by and so so so we're
done okay all right so so that's a path
coupling so I'm going to end here the
topic of colorings and maybe just
mention really quickly what the current
state state of this problem is so so
it's conjectured that you should be able
to show order n log n mixing as long as
q is bigger than or equal to Delta plus
2 but n log so it's so you know the best
the best q for which n log n mixing is
known is this cute is this to Delta we
know n squared log and mixing when q is
slightly below to Delta this is the
result by pakoda showing when q is
bigger than 11 / 6 delta that you have
polynomial mixing and then this is the
lower bound of hazing Sinclair that I
mentioned before and then there has been
a lot of work trying to analyze the
mixing time for the colorings chain in
restricted cases and trying to get fast
and log n mixing for smaller values of
Delta and the types of things that have
been studied are things like triangle
free graphs and large bound on the
maximum degree and you know the reason
for studying studying these sort of
things comes from the the picture that
we had before so if you look at this
case where the distance is decreasing in
the coupling you see that it's good for
you if you have a lot of colors here to
choose from which will decrease the
distance right and in these triangle
free graphs and strangle three graphs
and graphs of large maximum degree you
can make arguments that at certain times
as you're running this chain you will
have a large number of colors available
for you to for you to update in both
cases and decrease the distance other
approaches that have been taken with
non-markovian couplings so so all the
couplings that we've seen so far are
Markovian in the sense that when you
define the coupling you are you know
defining it based on what your current
pair of states is okay and you know in
general if you define it based on you
know the evolution of the pair of chains
until now that's a Markovian coupling
but remember that all you have to do is
couple the distributions PT X dot and PT
y dot and potentially you know you could
look at evolutions of these chains look
at future states and decide what the
coupling should be at time T so things
like that are called non-markovian
couplings and using those people have
also shown bounds on the mixing
this is work on pays and pagoda so I've
just put all these names here in a row
because various combinations of them
worked on these different cases okay so
so in the last bit I want to talk about
some exact sampling algorithms and so as
I said in the beginning the motivation
for this might be that you know so far
we've seen that you can get bounds on
the total variation distance but you
might want to actually get exact samples
using a Markov chain so how can you do
how can you do this type of thing so
here's an algorithm called coupling from
the past which was given by prop and
Wilson and it's motivated it's helpful
to look at the following example and ask
the following question so suppose our
suppose that we're looking at you know
to evolutions of the same Markov chain
maybe we're coupling them and we run
them until they come to the same state
you can ask does that mean that the
chain is at stationarity right so we've
shown that it does mean that the total
variation distance can be bounded but
does it mean that the variation distance
to stationary is zero so here's an
example which shows that that's not the
case so it's got two states and you're
moving out of a always with probability
1 and you're moving out of B would
probably have right so you're going to
be at be you know twice as often in the
long run and that tells you that the the
stationary distribution is one-third and
two-thirds on a and B but if you think
about running two copies of the chain
one from started at a and one started
from B then you see that they would
never meet a day because when it when
the chain is at a it always moves to be
in right in the next step right so you
can't me today
so the answer in this case is no because
a has probably one third in the in the
stationary distribution but the change
never meet there okay so so here is kind
of you know what one says about coupling
from the past gftp it happens to be the
case that if in a certain sense you run
the chain backwards or from the past and
I'll say what that is it's just a phrase
right now from a certain time so that
from that time all the trajectories go
and meet at one state then in fact
they're guaranteed to be drawn from the
stationary distribution so let's let's
see how something like that could be set
up ok so I'm going to describe something
called the random function
representation of a Markov chain so the
setup is that you have an ergodic Markov
chain with transition matrix P and we're
going to consider all functions then go
from Omega to Omega so they take state
and Omega and they map it to another
state in omega and script F will be
distributions over such functions and a
distribution over over such functions
will be called a random function
representation if the probability when
you draw a function according to script
f and apply it to a state X the
probability that you get a state why is
exactly the transition probability P of
going from X to Y
so let's take an example which which
will maybe make it clear let's consider
the simple random walk that we saw saw
last time so remember this is the walk
where the random block we're walking
around on the interval and up with
probability half down with probability
half but if I try to do it from the ends
then I just stay where I am we'll come
up with a random function representation
for this Markov chain so we're just
going to use two functions F and F prime
F of State I is defined to be the
minimum of i plus 1 and n so you just
try to add one to eye but if you go over
end then you just stay it in and you
know this this is exactly what happens
in the chain right and f prime of i is
going to be the maximum of i minus 1 and
0 so you try to subtract one but if you
become negative you just stay at zero
and script f is going to be uniform on
FN f prime so i claim that now you know
p script probabilities when the function
is drawn from script f that f of X is
equal to Y is exactly the transition
probability of the simple random walk on
the interval
so the result so one result is that
every transition matrix in fact has a
random function representation it need
not be unique there there could be many
ways you could define it and we notice
another thing that the random function
representation defines a coupling on
Omega in the following way that if I
take a pair of states and apply the same
F to both of them and i get f of X and F
of Y then the state's f of X and F of Y
are drawn according to the one-step
distributions right so it is a coupling
okay and in fact you could define this
coupling on not just you know a pair of
states but all the states of the chain
okay so so that's the random function
representation and it helps us set up
open from the past in the following way
so you start out by taking all the times
between minus infinity infinity and I'm
going to think of the time zero as the
present and negative x is the past and
positive x as the future to each one of
these times we're going to associate a
random function ft which is drawn from F
from script F
and once you've drawn these these
functions they're they're here to stay
so you just have this ft now if I
compose functions f0 f1 up to ft minus 1
then it's like applying the transition
matrix T times and I'm going to call
this f-zero of T applied to X okay so
this is you know a random state and it
satisfies the following property the
property that this random state is equal
to some state why is just the t-step
probability of being a [ __ ] given that
you started at X ok and now here is what
we'll call the backward simulation of
the chain from X so you have the state X
and you apply to it f of minus T apply
to that F of minus T plus 1 etc until
you get to F of minus 1 so you end up at
a random state and actually you know you
can see that we haven't done anything
very special i mean here we applied
these t random functions and here we
applied another T random functions so
far nothing interesting has happened but
we just call that a backward simulation
ok so now let's look at the following
thing suppose that capital S is a time
so that the following thing happens but
if I look at F 0 s the forward
simulation but on all this all the
states in omega what does that mean so f
09 et Omega is just the set of states f
0 T of X or
in omega set of state so it was it
capital s is the time so that the size
of this set becomes one right so if you
think of the coupling view of this
random function representation it means
that you look at these forward
simulations of you know every state in
omega and you look at a time s when all
of them have coalesced right they've all
become the same and we've seen that in
this case you may not be a you know at
stationary coupling from the past says
that suppose instead you find a time
capital s and look at this backwards
evolution okay of Omega which is just
defined you know to be the set of these
these random States you find a time
capital s such that this is true then in
that case the chain is stationary you
are drawing from from the stationary
distribution all right so so maybe I
should clarify that a little bit that
you know F minus s 0 of omega is equal
to some particular state right so let's
call it X and that state is drawn from
the stationary distribution so it's not
too difficult to see why it works out so
let's just do the calculation we're
going to assume the following fact that
if you look at F 0 of T of X in the
limit as T goes to infinity then that's
distributed according to the stationary
distribution right that is just the
forward evolution of the Markov chain
and if I look at F minus T 0 of X with T
going off to infinity then that is also
just an evolution of the chain and it's
also distributed according to the
station
distribution okay so suppose that
capital S is a time so that this is true
and take any tea which is bigger than s
so further so minus T is further back in
time all right so let's try to calculate
what the distribution of this state is f
minus T of 0 so we started X and you run
the chain from from minus T 20 all right
so so we apply it like this and this
just boils down to f of minus s of 0
applied to all this right okay now all
of this is just some random state let's
call it Y and so you have f of minus s
of 0 applied to some why but we assumed
that you know the size of this is one
okay so no matter what you plug in here
you just get a single state out so that
means that F of minus s of 0 of why
should be equal to f of minus s of 0 of
X so it's telling us that the district
the distributions of these two things
are the same and since we chose t
arbitrarily F of minus T of 0 has the
same distribution as f of minus infinity
0 which is the stationary distribution
alright so so so that's kind of you the
argument for the light works how would
you implement such a thing and you know
the examples out of it so here's a like
implementation in a picture and we've
done it for this simple random walk
chain okay and the idea is very simple
what you do is you try to find this
capital S so you decide your functions
ft for each t each time T and then you
start off at you know I'm minus 1 and
you run no copies of the chain started
from all the possible so maybe I should
have labeled it but these are these dots
they just represent 01 look to it the
interval right so you start copies of
the chain from all the possible states
and you do what your function tells you
so let's say that at time minus one we
chose the function to be F prime which
means go down so we do that to all of
the states and we end up at some new set
of states and if those chains have
coalesced then we found our capital s
okay if they have not then what you do
is you take you know one more time step
back in time and now you use the
function for time too and then you know
compose out with the function for time
minus one and you see whether you've
coalesced and you haven't in this case
and here we can see that if you go back
to minus 3 and the choice of our
functions happen to be up up and down
that in fact at zero you would go and
call us and now you're guaranteed that
that the sample that you've drawn is
from station we're not assuming that the
functions are bijective and in fact you
can see you know that the state on this
date they go they go and meet maybe I
didn't understand your question
ok so the f's are just you know some
some functions from Omega to Omega and
you know I put in a state and I get out
of state and I can do that in any way
that I want okay so okay so here here
are some of the issues with you know so
so this seems really great I mean we
just you know run copies of the chain
like this and wait till they I'll
coalesce and and and everything seems
good but here are some issues so you
know this random function representation
it defines a coupling on on the set of
states and choosing this random function
representation is up to us and it will
affect you know how how this random time
s is distributed so ideally you would
want to choose F so that your expected
as is small right and you actually
couple in a short amount of time the
second problem seems to be that we have
to keep track of all of the states of
the chain and look at all these
trajectories and you know for the random
walk maybe it's okay the simple random
walk on the interval but let's say you
have a very large state space like we
had for colorings or an easy model or
pots model or something then you have to
keep track of all these trajectories so
that could be quite inefficient but one
of the benefits is that even if you
don't have bounds on the mixing time
this gives you a way to get exact
samples okay and here is you know one
observation which which you know gets
around these issues in a certain case
this is monotone coupling from the past
so suppose there's a partial order on
your set of states which is respected by
the coupling so this is something that
we had in the simple random walk right
because if you have two states one
of the other and then you you apply this
coupling then you know one one stays a
greater than or equal to the other and
suppose in addition you have a maximal
state xmax in a minimal state X min then
it's enough to just watch the
trajectories started at x max and X min
right because everything else would stay
in between and once they converged
you'll be guaranteed that all of the
trajectories okay so this this can
actually be done for example in the
easing model where you can define a
partial order on the states and the all
plus and all- configurations are the
maximum and minimal states and other
models where you could do this our dimer
configurations of a hexagonal grid and
some bipartite independence okay so so i
wanted to say mmm maybe a tiny bit about
the bound for the n log n bound for
random shuffling but i think i've kind
of run out of time so so maybe else
there isn't it true that coupling from
the past only seems to work in cases
where you can prove some downed on the
mixing time anyway that does seem to be
the case I haven't looked so David
Wilson has this huge page on problems
were closed but
I was what is the advantage then let you
don't have an epsilon oh let's see so
well you might well it might be the case
that you don't have about I mean that's
the one advantage that i can think of
your time what's good doesn't work
compelling in real time it does well it
doesn't work in annex pc bill amount of
time in saying hello mark jerem did some
experiments with the forests and the
degree he ran it for was like a 20 by 20
grid it was fine but if you read on the
30 by 30 green it just ran for him I
just didn't come up and it seems quite
typical
I don't know of any any any exam thing
is come on it can't beat the mixing time
how could it but it took I mean if it
makes if it doesn't mix quickly it will
convert quickly for sure does give
example yeah I mean when is it important
to have an example I don't know
practically maybe you want to see what
you know random configuration looks like
the only if you're doing something like
you sound playing for proximate counting
it doesn't particularly matter
well questions